can these foods help you age backwards
well traveling back in time is currently
impossible but healthy food can help
support a long healthy life so what's
happening to our body as we age well
first of all we know that we have
remarkably a perhaps endless supply of
stem cells you've heard about stem cell
technology is getting a big push we
think about stem cells as these
primordial
pluripotent cells that are
undifferentiated they haven't decided
what they want to be they haven't
decided whether they want to be a
cartilage in your nose or a piece of
your heart muscle or a neuron in your
brain they're just kind of standing
around waiting for instructions hey it's
Evan Carmichael and I make these videos
because when I started my first business
I really struggled to believe myself I
was making 300 bucks a month and quit
I'm a business partner and the thing
that saved me was watching the stories
of successful entrepreneurs they gave me
strategies as well as hope and belief
that just maybe I could do it myself as
well and I hope that this video here
today helps you get a little bit more
belief in yourself because I still need
the videos for myself today too so today
let's learn what you should eat every
day to increase your Health and
Longevity enjoy
it turns out that we always have stem
cells in our body uh some of you may
have had your stem cells harvested from
your fat and injected in a joint or a
shoulder
you may have had them injected in your
heart muscle some of you have probably
traveled to Mexico to get placental stem
cells or embryo stem cells but that's
another subject the point is we have
stem cells available to us but
they just sit there and twiddle their
thumbs until they're called into action
so what we want to do as we advance in
years is to continuously call these stem
cells into action and the more we're
learning about what stem cells do the
more exciting our options become
first of all there are foods that
support stem cell growth
interestingly and out greens and
particularly chlorophyll and spirulina
actually have been shown to keep stem
cells healthy if you really want to know
more about this visit our episode number
with the founder of energy bits which
are both chlorella and
spirulina bits that you can chew and
there's a lot of exciting news on this
front
perhaps one of the most really exciting
news is we know that the wall of our gut
is probably the most important
determinant for how well we age and for
how long we live and as I showed in the
longevity Paradox book there's very
strong evidence that as long as the wall
of your gut which is the same surface
area as a tennis court is intact
then you will continue to be healthy and
not wear out
so why talk about stem cells well it
turns out
one of the biggest set of stem cells is
in the wall of our gut
the wall of our gut is constantly
replenished we constantly Slough off
these cells and replace them with new
cells and the stem cells are what do
this now I've shown in my research that
vitamin D is essential to make those
stem cells actually turn in to new
intestinal cells and in my research the
higher your vitamin D level the more you
encourage those intestinal stem cells to
do their thing
the second exciting news is that we now
know that
polyphenols those wonderful bright
rainbow colors in fruits and vegetables
and that you can also take as
supplements and powders are used by
bacteria to not only live but to produce
compounds that further enhance stem cell
proliferation in the wall of our gut
absurd exciting finding is that the more
you practice time restricted eating the
more you compress your eating window to
preferably about six to eight hours a
day what does that look like it means
break fast at 11 and finish dinner at
seven or break fast at noon and finish
dinner at six or combinations the more
you do that
the more you allow for repair of your
gut wall and the more you stimulate stem
cell differentiation in the rest of your
body now why does that happen well it
turns out there's
new
zombie cells that have been discovered
recently that are so named because they
are cells that are no longer functioning
properly in our body but have not
decided to die and they're called
senescent cells and there's a ton of
them in our body sadly the more
senescent cells that we have the more
inflammation that they produce and the
more they occupy spaces where normal
healthy cells could be
now cells die in one of two ways and how
they die is critically important
if these senescent cells eventually die
they literally die by exploding and it's
got a name called
apoptosis it literally explodes and
spews cellular debris around
our immune system our white blood cells
go oh my gosh you know there's been an
explosion there's been a disaster and
we're going to be called to the scene
and it actually produces more
inflammation
on the other hand by intermittent
fasting by time restricted eating what
happens is that these cells rather than
exploding undergo what's called
autophagy
autophagy means
self-eat and simplistically what happens
is the cell literally
reprocesses all the components within
the cell basically takes the cell down
to the studs and rebuilds it recycling
the components and so we can actually
tell cells to not explode but to
reprocess themselves and start all over
again so autophagy is what you want it
rebuilds cells without the damage
without explosion how do you do that
time restricted eating
how do you get stem cells to
differentiate time restricted eating how
do you get stem cells in the wall of
your gut to do their thing vitamin D and
time restricted eating all sorts of
great techniques
now if you remember in my last book
unlocking the keto code I stressed
another way to enhance stem cell
function and that's mitochondrial and
coupling we now know that mitochondrial
and coupling that is having mitochondria
not work as hard as they need to
simultaneously stimulating more
mitochondria to be born called
mitogenesis is Hallmark to having a
healthy body well into our later years
mitochondrial and coupling is promoted
by ketosis by eating polyphenols by
practicing intermittent fasting so you
can see how all of these techniques that
have stood the test of time excuse the
pun all produce what we're looking for
and that is fresh new healthy cells
regardless of our age and the exciting
thing that I've seen in my practice and
other people have documented is about
every three months
we throw out a cell and build a new one
so that if you're using quality
materials if you're stimulating
autophagy
you can actually get a whole new you
every three months with good material
and that's why you see such healthy
agers in their late 90s early 100s who
do not look old who do not act old and
that's because they've been practicing
this throughout your life finally
mushrooms mushrooms are an unbelievable
food for supporting mitochondrial
uncoupling I don't care which kind of
mushroom you get but eat a host of
different mushrooms get mushroom
supplements but most grocery stores now
are carrying multiple kinds of mushrooms
if you have a choice between the white
button mushroom and the darker ones get
the darker ones okay that's how to live
to a ripe old age and die young rule
number two is get enough omega-3 fatty
acids with Sean Stevenson this is so
freaking important I don't even want
this to if anybody does anything from
this episode I want to make sure that
you're getting in enough omega-3 fatty
acids in the form of DHA and EPA so
number one
DHA and EPA have expressed Lanes if you
want to think about the blood-brain
barrier being like a toll booth they
have Express passes to get into the
brain like your brain sucks them up like
in droves because they're needed for
structure of your brain cells
Omega-3s function as structural fats in
your brain creating plasticity
creating stability and signal
transduction so your brain cells can
actually talk to each other
without omega-3s goes wrong real fast to
the degree one of the craziest studies
in the book they found that the folks
who had the lowest intake of DHA and EPA
had the highest rate of brain shrinkage
all right your your brain literally
shrinks rapidly if you're not getting
these fats in and so what it was was
just under 1.2 teaspoons a day anything
under that
increase the rate of brain shrinkage
what are the best three foods or
supplements to get your um
DHA and EPA
okay perfect
food first food first the general
neurology found that folks who consume
Just One Seafood meal per week do in
fact perform better on cognitive skills
tests I think that's a direct one-to-one
response to those Omega-3s but if you if
you're not taking uh if you're taking a
vegan or vegetarian protocol I've got
news for good news for you too but food
first and then of course there's
grass-fed beef in that same Spectrum has
Omega-3s a high ratio of Omega-3s uh
eggs the best food source though Tom is
not the fish the fatty fish but the
fatty fish eggs so salmon Roe and caviar
can have three times more DHA and EPA
than the fish itself and then we've got
from there most of the studies done on
DHA and EPA is done via fish oil all
right so I did share some studies in the
book that are just really shocking when
it comes official but then from there
the next rung down is krill oil right
Krill that's the microscopic shrimp
super dense in astaxanthin which makes
your body absorb Omega-3s even better
it's incredible that might be for
somebody who's doing a vegetarian
protocol wherever that lies on your
ethics krill oil might be a savior for
your brain if anything everybody today
even if you're taking a vegan protocol
please get yourself an algae oil right a
high quality algae oil it has the DHA
and EPA there but we don't have clinical
studies now to see its Effectiveness but
we do know that it's there and I just
don't want you to wait around for that
data DHA is so important for your brain
just to be clear this is the plant
source is ala right that's what you find
in chia seeds and flax seeds and hemp
seeds I would have patients get flaxseed
oil for years I was missing the point
it's not the same as DHA and EPA but
it's so important for your brain that
your body can convert some ala into DHA
but you can lose depending on your
metabolism your unique metabolic
fingerprint you can lose 90 percent of
the converter process and so you'll have
to eat
bags of chia seeds a day to get what
your brain needs you know it's just not
doable
and plus you probably want to leave the
bathroom at some point
um so that's that's that part and I also
want to share this really quickly with
uh Omega-3s and omega-6s this was a
study and this was published in the
journal nutrients and it found that a
large increase in the ratio of omega-6s
in the diet compared to Omega-3s
directly increases our risk of obesity
but here's the most important part
listen to this
this another study and this was
highlighted and then I broke this down
I'm getting giggy giddy right now
another study highlighted in each mortar
found that an imbalance in omega-6s to
Omega-3s leads to dysfunction of your
hunger related hormones and increase fat
storage even with calories being the
same
even with calories being the same people
with a higher intake of omega-6s gained
more weight
and more body fat it had more
dysfunction to their hunger related
hormones all right epicolor controller
Omega-3s help to reduce inflammation
omega-6s are not bad but we need more
Omega-3s right now because it could
become such a mega6 dominate Society
rule number three is only love foods
that love you back with Dr Daniel Amen I
come up with this new phrase I just love
so much
that you only want to love food that
loves you back that you're in a
relationship with food I think 30
percent of the mental health problems in
America are related to our
terrible diet
that you are what you eat in large part
and if you're eating
I call them the weapons of mass
destruction highly processed pesticide
sprayed high glycemic low fiber
food-like substances stored in plastic
containers you're not going to be
healthy you poison your gut you're
poisoning your brain and I publish three
studies now the last one on 35
000 scans one of the world's largest
Imaging studies
Tom you will not believe this there was
a linear correlation on virtually every
area of the brain as people's weight
went up the activity and blood flow in
their brain went down I believe it
unfortunately
healthy weight
overweight obese morbidly obese in a
linear fashion when I saw those graphs
when I was doing the research I was just
like horrified and I come from a family
of fat people my dad used to hate when
I'd say that I have a brother that's 150
pounds overweight and a sister is the
same thing and I know if I just ate
everything that looked good to me I
would be too and now I'm not having that
especially because I don't want a small
brain right right and and people go
that's fat shaming and I feel terrible
about it because 72 percent of the
country is overweight think about that I
mean how insane is that 42 percent of
people are obese the pandemic made it
worse
we should be worried about that because
the extra fat on your body produces
inflammatory cytokines and we know
inflammation is a major cause of
depression and dementia the fat on your
body takes healthy testosterone which we
need which men and women need and it
turns it into unhealthy cancer-promoting
forms of estrogen that's a bad thing fat
stores toxins we need to get serious
about being in a healthy way with
healthy food
and so diet is critical exercise
supplementation I think is really
important I did a study 97 percent of
the population
low in omega-3 fatty acids and so
finding ways to supplement about 80
percent of us are deficient in vitamin D
yeah in a pandemic that's not okay nope
right because people with low vitamin D
actually die more if they get covered
19. also to make sure you're actually
taking action after watching this video
I've designed a special free worksheet
just for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number four is be stress free
with David Sinclair before we move on
from balding to graying there's this
sort of like
hair thing that a lot of people are
familiar with when they age and that is
it stops growing on your head it starts
growing other places you get in your
nose your eyebrow hairs start to get
long you get in your ears
what's going on here we don't really
know why hairstyles growing in the wrong
places as annoying as it is probably I
think what's happening is that we have
this evolutionary program where we used
to be a lot hairier six to ten million
years ago and those stem cells are still
ready to grow thick hair in our ears on
our nose wherever it you don't want it
to grow and that the changes in the
structure of the of the DNA the what we
call the epigenome
is changing over time and that those
regions that are normally silent in the
ears so you don't get big hairy ears are
unraveling as part of the aging process
so these are parts of ancient genetic
code that have been uh that have been
allowed to escape from the from the
histones and now they're readable by the
cells right and we become our ancestors
unfortunately so shave or pluck that out
for now but that what that means is we
would predict that if we can slow down
aging using the methods that we've
talked about in this in other episodes
we should also prevent that process from
happening or at least delay it till much
later in life would that be the case
with graying hair too uh it could be
because graying is part of not just a
genetic program but can be accelerated
by things that are also known to
accelerate aging itself such as
psychological stress and we this is
really interesting because we know from
some fairly recent research that stress
plays a cue I mean it's always been sort
of known oh you're going to make me go
gray right my grandmother you're gonna
make me go great you're already great
but
um we've long known that gray hair is
associated with stress what's
coming out now is that it doesn't have
to be permanent it's been known for
probably centuries that you can have
these binary colored hairs where they at
the tip of the hair it's dark and then
it's gray in the middle and then dark
again at the bottom and people have
wondered what the heck is going on and
just recently in 2021 a group of
researchers had a look at what was
happening in people's lives during that
gray hair growth period and they found
that they were remarkably stressful
periods of those people lives were where
they they didn't stop working they
didn't they didn't sleep they didn't go
on a vacation and so I think it's very
clear that stress can induce gray hair
loss of color from the hair but what's
also remarkable about about that finding
is that it proves that gray hair is
reversible which means that what we're
talking about here is is an epigenetic
effect sure I mean anything that is
genetic is is essentially irreversible
so this is an epigenetic effect what I
would imagine is that after you've been
gray for many many years it's going to
be
very difficult to reverse that but in
the early phases when you're getting
this spattering of gray and color grain
color you are able to get those those
packages of DNA back to where they were
when you were young using some of the
methods that we're talking about today
and we've talked about in other episodes
and this has to do with those stem cells
that produce pigment they're melanocytes
yep and these sit right next to our hair
shafts they do and they they inject the
color as the Keratin is being put
together into that that hair shaft and
the prevailing Theory as to why we get
gray is that these melanocytes die
through a process called apoptosis
hopefully that isn't true I think it's
true for very late in life but what
we're seeing in this new study is that
they become dysfunctional before they
die and that's a period that we have a
chance to recover their function and
prevent them from dying and there are a
number of ways that I could think of at
least to reverse that and prevent them
from dying one way though would be to
use some of these adversity mimetics to
get that epigenome to reset that's what
some researchers have done in mice at
least in a fairly recent study actually
this year
um using a combination compound
including cyclosporine a minoxidil which
is the cream that we talked about
earlier and then another pigment
promoting drug we dug into this a little
today and got really excited by what we
found yeah because the paper tries to
obscure what this actual chemical is
this age reversing
um and pigment promoting drug turns out
it's called tacrolamus which is a very
similar molecule to rapamycin or also
known as serolimus which we've mentioned
in earlier episodes is one of the main
drugs that can extend lifespan and
inhibit this complex of proteins called
mtor that responds to fasting and like
cyclosporane it's an immunosuppressant
which means it's an adversity mometics
it's it's showing your cells that times
are not all that great right now right
it's making your stem cells freak out
that things are going to be rough and
maybe we should be rejuvenated and start
growing a little better I just want to
mention this cyclosporin a it's really
interesting you said it's an
immunosuppressant it's used to prevent
organ rejection in my lab we found it
also rejuvenates mitochondria through
actually making sure that What's called
the mitochondrial permeability
transition pore or mptp is preserved
long story short I think this
combination of cyclosporinate from
mitochondrial activity
minoxidil which we talked about is blood
flow improved blood flow and this
pigment promoting promoting drug which
is basically an analog of rapamycin
which simulates a fasting response is
the triple combo for a hair
repigmentation this is not yet ready for
human use undoubtedly there's probably
somebody trying this out in Hollywood
but as of right now this is still
sometime in the future I think so you
know people already try and rapamycin as
a drug 10 milligrams uh every week or so
this isn't this is only being done by a
few people under doctor supervision but
I could imagine that there will be
products made available to the general
public one day that would definitely
restore hair color it's not a miracle
that this happens it's just science and
we're going to figure it out rule number
five is do intermittent fasting with
Raul jandile what if you wanted to work
on focus and cognition these things are
harder to test but when you go into the
big Neuroscience journals they speak
about intermittent fasting and the best
way I can explain it is your brain's a
hybrid vehicle
it grew it evolved through through
thousands and thousands and thousands of
years of lots of food scarcity you
didn't eat all the time and so it's got
a backup mechanism called Ketone so
after 16 hours
if you don't put glucose in
and the liver is done releasing the
glucose it's held onto
through glycogen reserves then it'll
start burning fat
will clip off those oxygens and
hydrogens and they'll make ketones out
of it intermittent fasting can also help
you lose weight I think that's why most
people are interested in it but it's the
way the brain prefers to get its fuel
source and it's based on a diet
lessons about dieting learn through
controlling epilepsy and seizures in
kids in areas where there's no medicine
so I was in Ukraine and when they don't
have medicine or a type of seizure
seizure abnormal electrical activity of
the brain just like an arrhythmia would
be an abnormal electrical activity of
the heart
they would just feed them all fat diet
you could smell it in the hospitals so
something about an all-fat diet forcing
you into just using ketones
now intermittent fasting is back and
forth glucose and then ketones glucose
and then ketones but for kids if you
just get them almost nearly all Ketone
as the source that goes up to the brain
through an all-fat diet
their seizure rates go down you know so
that's proof that food changes mind
because the mind is the electricity
sparking through that flesh food will
change the electricity detectable
measurable electricity in your brain
food affects mind food affects brain
with that premise we can talk about okay
mind diet will hold off dementia and
intermittent fasting might make you feel
like you've had a cup of coffee once
you're getting a rhythm out it's not
going to make you smarter but it'll
bring you to your most Focus to bring
you to your most attentive it's not good
oh I'm intermittent fasting and now I
can do physics it's it's not like that
it's your personal best and then the
habits you demonstrate to your family by
trying to be at your personal best and
then your kids see that and your friends
see that and I think that's how you
impact generalization change is to have
uh capable people demonstrate hey it's
not hard and this is the best we can do
for ourselves it's really interesting I
have a very different relationship with
intermittent fasting so I intermittent
fast a lot so I'm fasting almost 20
hours a day how does it feel awesome but
it does it isn't additional Clarity for
me so what I find is that it changes my
relationship to hunger so I'm not
thinking about food in the way that I
would be thinking about out food if I'm
eating over a longer period of time
because I'm in ketosis so if you took my
blood not now probably because I just
had a big meal about three hours ago but
if you had taken my blood this morning
at like 10 o'clock a thousand percent I
was probably posting a 1.5 ish and when
I'm in that range I feel great but I
don't feel extra but I find it is
extraordinary for fat loss so the reason
I'm doing it now is so I cycle
throughout the year so in the winter I
worry a lot less about carrying a bit of
fat so I probably fluctuate during the
year five to seven pounds probably and
then for the summer then I'll sharpen
back up and then again the the cycle
repeats so
that I find it really effective for I
find it really effective for changing my
relationship to food so that I don't
need to eat if I were going to miss a
meal not a big deal if my only choice to
eat something bad versus to skip a meal
then I find that it's it's just a
different relationship right so here's
where I think I understand it a little
bit differently it's not like you expect
Clarity when you pop into ketosis
because it's been 16 hours after you've
eaten there's just your last meal it's
just the going back and forth
over a few weeks over a few months those
months you'll have maybe more clarity
than the months before when you weren't
doing I have a hypothesis about that
this test obviously we're not gonna be
able to figure it out here but my gut
instinct is if you're used to a high
carbohydrate diet a thousand percent
you'd be like holy this is a revolution
my life is so much better I'm clear all
of that
but because I don't almost ever have
non-vegetable carbohydrates in my diet
because if I were to cheat then I get it
then I am a little bit foggy so the
Delta is less for you since you already
started with a better deal yeah so from
a Clarity perspective this lay person so
discount the out of it but this
layperson's Vibe is or hypothesis is is
that this is a lack of carbohydrate
thing that gives People non-vegetable
based carbohydrate that gets people the
clarity but there's even another benefit
to it which is it will radically alter
your relationship to hunger is probably
a better way to say it than food yeah
which is pretty interesting yeah so
that's the whole psychology of the the
feed forward of you know forward Loop
cycle of eating and then I don't know
that what does that mean well it's just
the the fact that you get a rush when
you eat yes you know it's just it's
you're supposed to I mean and fat tastes
richer because somehow you know we
figured out it was more advantageous you
know to have this because it's more
nutritious at least from calorie point
of view and so those things are set
inside us I mean if it's good for us it
gives us a rush
sometimes if it's bad for us it gives us
a rush and I love the complexity of that
I love that animals get high I love that
some people think that I stop there it's
I totally am with you but explain to
people how animals get high well they
eat fermented food they Berry stuff
underneath they they search certain
things in the environment
that are uh you know psychoactive
meaning it changes the way they feel and
what's unique about these substances
like cannabinoids or even nicotine that
when you as a scientist I'm reading
papers and it says
cannabinoid receptors we have named
scientific terms for cannabis inside our
body there is a nicotine receptor
nicotinic receptors so that active
agreement ingredient from tobacco I'm
not saying smoke
but just to understand that the
chemicals in plants have perfect locks
for which they serve the keys in our
bodies we we grew with the plants we
change with the plants we use the plants
to our advantage and now the the plants
and the food have have gone the other
way and it's a disadvantage to for us
and the biggest problem I don't
understand because we're eating too much
so before food scarcity
was uh an advantage
because it kept us from interim it was
intermittent fasting by you know by
necessity and that if you think about it
just conceptually it's just another
hypothesis
if during times of hunger you were less
sharp or lack of food made you dull
rather than sharpened your wits about
where the lion was or where the other
where was the berry where was the fruit
where were the shellfish in southern
South Africa if it made you dull that
wouldn't be a positive thing so I think
I think it makes intuitive sense also
that just a little bit and with all
respect I know people can't get food
throughout the world I've traveled the
world I know there's bad food everywhere
but on an intellectual level for people
trying to take it to the next level is
is a bit of food scarcity can actually
sharpen your mind and Neuroscience is
trying to understand
at the molecular level what's going on
what's swimming into the brain and which
receptors are being turned on but I
think I think it does make some
intuitive sense and rule number six the
last one before some very special bonus
Clips is think differently with Marissa
Pierre I'm gonna tell you today too
really exciting things one is if you
want to
you can become younger so many years ago
when I was younger I wrote my first book
about how to actually slow down aging
and it really is possible and when I was
writing my book one of my dearest
friends came to me and she was 35 and
she'd actually started going to the
menopause and no children she was
devastated and I like look you can
actually reverse the age of your eggs
and your womb she's like really I'm like
yeah sure so I worked with her and she
had a baby which was amazing and then
she did go back in the menopause but
many years later and she was fine
because she had her family
so when I was writing my first book many
years ago I met this amazing woman
called Ellen Langer and she had done
this really cool experiment I'm going to
share it with you so she took a group of
men or men of 75 and this was in 1979 I
met her many years later
75 year old men who went into Retreat
and it was
it was and that means that
everything was shot and it looked as if
it was from 1959 so all the music that
was piped in was from 1959 all the
magazines and every newsreel and every
paper and every program was from 1979
and sorry 59 and it was furnished to be
1959 and it was an experiment before
they went in they tested their age so
this is what you can do if you want to
be younger changing your thoughts and
beliefs can make you younger can make
you live longer can make you look and
feel better give you a great memory into
your 90s and Beyond and it can keep you
fit and active and healthy and I'm not
going to tell you I'm going to show you
because I'm a great believer that you
believe it when you see it so you see
there it says they tested their
biological age no point your chronolog
age means you're 75 that is so
unimportant your birth certificate age
throw it away never refer to it again it
doesn't mean a thing because we age on
our own timetable so you have an age
Maybe
I'd say someone who was 40 that's your
age of your birth certificate if you're
a runner then your age of your organs is
very different a runner of 40 will have
a hearted lungs of 30 but knees are 15
if they run in the sun skin of 52. so
your biological age is completely
different and you can change it and the
thing that changes it is your
psychological age the age you feel I'll
tell you more about that in a minute so
they did all these tests they're hearing
their Vision their grip even the length
of their fingers
and their blood and their hormones and
all these things and after a week of
pretending it was 20 years earlier
pretending it was 1959 not 1970 and they
all every single one of them reversed
their age by a minimum
of seven years because they did all
these tests again and they were like wow
these guys are seven to ten years
younger of course we said yeah but it's
because they had a holiday for a week so
she has to have a control group so I'm
just getting used to that and the
control group also went on a whole day
for a week to the same place but they
had normal Furniture it was 1979 they
actually got older I guess they didn't
like that modern music but they didn't
reverse their aging at all anyway the
BBC said wow you know this is so cool so
the BBC in 2010 said we're going to
recreate this but even better so they
made a closed Retreat and they made it
35 years earlier so they took a group of
men and women it wasn't just men
and they were between the age of 78 and
88 and they took them to a closed
Retreat it was 2010 but it all looked
like it was 1975 the music was from 1975
the TV shows were from 1975 they have to
wear Badges of themselves from 1975 and
every magazine was from 1975.
and they found what was extraordinary is
that one of them went in on sticks one
of them could practically not walk and
the same thing happened within a week
they had all reversed their aging by 12
years that's more than a year a day and
they asked one of them in particular
what did you do to reverse your aging
because the one who was there in there
on crutches was actually running around
the garden there was a woman called
Sylvia Sims and she said to this day she
now goes to all people's homes and
teaches them something which is you can
get older you do not have to get old and
he said I forgot to be old I slipped
back into that world of 35 years ago I
forgot I was 88. he'd been really
depressed there was another guy there
called Lionel Blair he was actually tap
dancing on stage so this was a great
thing to do because what you have to
understand about aging is it cannot be
defined no one has ever been able to
Define aging there are tribes there are
groups there's an eyelid in Greece where
they have some of the longest living
people in the world that I all have some
stuff in common which I'll share with
you
but actually what we think of Aging you
know what it is it is massive disuse of
the body followed by Massive disuse of
the brain because the brain is brutal a
brain has what I call use it
or lose it and if you use it you don't
lose it and if you don't use it you do
lose it so once the BBC had done this
test and it was so amazing they said
well let's do more tests so they took a
group of people volunteers off the
street and they said walk into a room
and just make sentences of these words
they had a few more words too so they
went into the room they filmed them
walking in and they got a pen and they
made a sentence with wines fragile
sentimental obedient when they filmed
them leaving they said it was so odd
they were walking 20 slower they really
thought they were fragile and they were
walking like they'd go old
and then of course they took another
group in the room and they said make
sentences out of these words and they
said they practically bounded out of the
room they were springing out of there
all the same age because they were using
young words
and the words you use have an actual
effect on your body you see your brain
listens to every word you say if you go
oh my God I look so old your brain goes
okay and that's permanent but if you go
oh I look a little tired I look a little
dehydrated I look a little stressed your
brain goes yeah but tomorrow you won't
because some words are permanent and
some words are not
so don't ever go I'm so old I'm too old
I look old I can't do that at my age I
hear people going oh I forgot the milk
it's my age is that really because my
kid comes home from school every week
without her swimming trunks and then her
lunch and then she's forgotten her PE
care and I never go with your age you're
just so old and you only have to hang
out on a children's cloakroom to see how
much they forget stuff but we don't go
to their age or people go I need my
sleep at night I'm like my four-year-old
needed her sleep when she was four but I
never added to it it's her age actually
it kind of was her age but as people get
older they I forgot because my age I
look old because I'm old my knees hurt
because I'm old you've got to start
disregarding your age if you want to age
incredibly well never mention your age
don't refer to it because it doesn't
matter so here's the next you see this
is what aging is it's an expectation
that you live up to you know um you can
go to old people's home and see people
sitting with their remote control
clicking through the TV shows getting
older
because when hope dies old age runs to
meet you but people who don't do that
who still work you know professors of 90
have the same brain neurons as
professors of 30 because they use their
brain all the time so you want to age
well have a different expectation of
what aging is scientists know that you
can boost your immune system just by
thinking differently which is exactly
what those people did with the BBC test
they thought they were younger
meditation can make you I promise 15
years younger don't believe me go and
ask Emily she'll tell you because you
can't stop yeah she's really 62 but
that's a secret
and I'm really 82.
but we don't ever discuss our age you
see you make different chemicals
when you're happy when you're depressed
your whole immune system is depressed
with you
there's so this is such a Hot Topic
um you know when you just put into like
keto fasting all this stuff you're just
like okay carnivore or even like you
know feel like Michaela Peterson has
made the Lion's diet a thing now so what
is it what are you trying to say with
this book what is the diet what are you
saying is the problem and what is the
solution
well so I've I've had a ketogenic
version of my
diet since I did it and it's in actually
all the books and interestingly enough
if you look at the ketogenic version of
the plant Paradox there's a whole lot of
carbohydrates in there and people do
extremely well on that program so when I
was doing the energy Paradox my last
book I wanted to kind of explain
how ketones made your mitochondria the
little energy producing organelles in
all of our cells really super efficient
and really highly efficient at burning
fat for fuel and I like to document with
studies with evidence what I say and so
as I'm looking up all the studies that
I'd
accrued and started reading them even
closer and go wait a minute
this is everything I'm saying in all the
keto experts are saying is wrong
keto is ketones are a horrible fuel they
are not some super fuel they yeah sorry
um this is I knew you were going to tell
me something that was going to be like
what yeah and I go what and I go wait a
minute you know but you know I'm
teaching and everybody's teaching and
all the keto experts are teaching that
they're a super fuel and they're not uh
this was actually worked out uh at
Harvard in the NIH uh back in the 70s
80s 90s and even in the 2000s on humans
so
um briefly
um even at a full ketogenic diet where
you're producing massive amounts of
ketones
ketones can only Supply 30 of the energy
needs of a human being 30 percent
and yeah sorry
um this was Dr Owens work from Harvard
uh published in 2004 and even at full
ketosis ketones can only meet 60 to 70
percent of the brain's energy needs and
the Brain still needs 30 to 40 percent
glucose sugar to run oh wow because I
feel like the the word on the street is
like you can use fat for fuel or or
sugar for fuel those are your two fuels
the main fuels that they use their body
uses first that's true that's true
um muscles will use ketones after a
three-day starvation fast muscles will
use ketones as a fuel but as you go
beyond three days muscles shift to using
free fatty acids as a fuel and could
care less about ketones
um so what are ketones doing well
ketones free fatty acids are
mitochondrial love they'll make they'll
make ATP just fine the problem with free
fatty acids are that they're too big to
get through What's called the
blood-brain barrier it's literally a
barrier for things to pass through to
get to the brain and so you could have
free fatty acids floating all around uh
but they can't get to the brain so what
do we get free fatty acids from so free
fatty acids come out of our fat okay
okay
that's an energy that gets liberated
from the fat that can be used in the
body correct as a fuel okay your
mitochondria normally if you have what's
called metabolic flexibility
you should be able to burn sugar as a
fuel and then as the sugar dries up you
shift to burning free fatty acids as a
fuel and the best example is a hybrid
car
while you're burning gasoline you're
hopefully charging the battery so it's
like well you're eating carbohydrates
and protein whatever is extra you'll put
into storage is fat
if the gasoline runs out then we call on
the battery to start supplying power for
keep us moving so the fat is our battery
and free fatty acids are broken pulled
out of the battery to power the engine
when glucose is no longer available
that's how we're designed now the bad
news is that and I talk about this in
the book 50 percent of normal weight
Americans do not have metabolic
flexibility 50 cannot switch cannot tap
their battery overweight Americans 88 of
them are metabolically inflexible and
obese Americans 99
are metabolically inflexible so the
important thing about this with ketones
is that
ketones are only made normally by free
fatty acids coming out of fat cells
going to the liver and the liver
converts them into short chain saturated
fats that are water soluble called
ketones or Ketone bodies and they can go
to the brain and serve as a temporary
emergency fuel for the brain until we
find some glucose
okay so those are used right away it's
just whole it's like there's a delay
it's just yeah it's like hold on you
know food's coming hold on don't die but
you know this will do for now
the problem is if you're not
metabolically flexible and you stop
eating or even you eat uh 80 fat diet
insulin people have heard of insulin
resistance by now if you're not
metabolically flexible you have a high
insulin level and Insulin actually
blocks fat from being released from fat
stores so you could have tons of fat but
if your insulin level is elevated and I
can tell you that most Americans insulin
level is elevated then you could stop
eating you could eat an 80 fat diet and
it may take weeks for insulin to fall
enough that you can start putting free
fatty acids out to be turned into ketone
and that explains the keto flu the
Atkins blues and it's not even that easy
to get into ketosis from what I've
learned it's actually very I listened to
Dr Rhonda Patrick talking about that and
how she had to keep testing herself and
she just had to keep pouring fat on the
things to even get into ketosis and she
could get kicked out super easily by too
much spinach
but I've got the trick okay
and that's unlocking the keto code
believe it or not you don't have to eat
a lot of fat to get into ketosis okay
yay yeah one of so one of the tricks
that I in all my books
um most people now have heard of MCT oil
medium chain triglycerides median chain
triglycerides uh
are absorbed as a fat in a totally
different way than any other fat they're
absorbed directly through the wall of
our gut and they unlike any other fat go
directly to our liver you know do not
pass go to not collect 200 and are made
instantly into ketones
no matter what you're eating so you
could you could have a plate of spinach
you could have a fruit salad please
don't but you could have a fruit salad
and take a tablespoon of MCT oil and you
will be in ketosis
cheese nice that's really helpful I've
got some of that yeah now uh
mct's menu chain triglycerides and
generally are named after the goat copra
and so there's capric acid caprylic acid
caprylic acid they're all words for go
why did they name it for goat turns out
that goat milk and sheep milk is 30
medium chain triglycerides MCTS
yes can I eat goat cheese then oh you
can have goat cheese you can have sheep
cheese you can have goat yogurt you can
have sheep yogurt I'm going to switch
out for my cashew fake goat cheese
cashew and for the real thing yeah and
so you will make ketones just by eating
goat cheese and sheep cheese and I've
got tons of recipes in the book of so
you could I mean you could you know have
yourself some goat yogurt and put some
polyphenols which we'll talk about in a
bit maybe in it and you'll go into
ketosis let's be clear nobody knows what
the perfect diet is even when it comes
to fasting it's all largely based on
rodent studies so what I can tell you
about the rodent studies which I'm very
familiar with is that if you take a
rodent and reduce its calories by 25
percent for its whole life it will live
longer 30 but it'll be really miserable
and aggressive and that's true for us as
well I've tried calorie restriction for
about a week and I gave up I was pretty
angry but what we discovered our my
colleagues discovered is that if you
it's not just what you eat it's when you
eat that's important and what's been
found is that if as long as you have
that period of hunger
um in a mouth so you can feed them every
other day then they can gorge themselves
as much as they want and they do they
eat about 90 of what a mouse having free
access to food would eat
but they they have the same longevity
benefit as a mouse that's always been
hungry and if that's true what that
means is for us is that we can enjoy
life as long as we have that period of
hunger once a day or maybe twice a week
and I believe the only reason we age
um you know we could live for a thousand
years otherwise the only reason we age
is that our repair systems become
complacent you mentioned that what what
is beneficial for you when you're young
comebacks to bite you when you're old
what we think is that these repair
systems are very good when we're young
so the idea is it's called antagonistic
pleiotropy and I think it's right and
that is that we evolve to stay healthy
and alive and fit till we're 40 and then
the forces of natural selection decline
after that because we've essentially
bred we've often had children but we
don't need to stick around beyond that
and building a body that will last a
thousand years is pointless at that you
know so most species only live as long
as they need to to reproduce and then a
little bit more
if you're a mouse that could die within
two years they only build a body that
lasts two years if you're a whale that
has no Predators you can live for a
couple of hundred years that makes more
sense
why why does the whale live for a couple
hundred years like I would say it's
pretty safe to say certainly at some
point in our past we became a pretty
clear apex predator it's not that things
couldn't take us out but I mean by and
large obviously look at how far we've
come they didn't so why would we only
live to 40 is it that whales continue to
breed and be useful in that sense so
that's really super interesting and very
few people talk about this
the reason is that we were not at the
apex of the food chain until recently
but in a world where we typically would
die from starvation or from war a lot of
men didn't make it to 40 because of that
we were at the middle of the food chain
only now we we actually barely have a
chance of dying before 70 or 80 unless
we're unlucky
you know give us another five million
years of evolution we could evolve 200
year life spans that's what should
happen if evolution continues a whale
has been at the Apex for about 30
million years and they've been allowed
to evolve those long lifespans we are
just like them we share most of their
genes they're warm-blooded they produce
milk they're conscious they're basically
Us in the sea so anyone who says we've
reached our maximum limit doesn't know
what they're talking about
talk to me about this notion of
resetting the biological clock how do we
do that what's the mechanism and so
obviously going hungry occasionally
exercise is going to help but I know
that you have a regiment that I'll
lovingly call a regimen of drugs or
precursors to things that we can take
what can we do to reset that biological
clock
well there are different levels to
resetting aging there are three levels
that we know of the first is pretty easy
to reset or to to manipulate these are
the proteins that turn genes on and off
very quickly we call them transcription
factors and they they basically read a
gene and make a protein that's what they
do
that's level one that's easy go a little
bit hungry that'll change level two is a
little bit harder the level two is not
just changing which genes are quickly
turned on and off but actually silencing
genes for for a long time and this is
where my enzymes that we work on the
sirtuins come into play let's go back to
the Pac-Man they clip off acetyls off
these packing proteins you spool up the
hose and it becomes becomes locked in
that that Gene gets silenced for a long
time so to do that you can exercise you
can diet but you also I think you need a
little bit of help as well
what gets really interesting and this is
something most scientists don't even
know about yet is level three the Deep
layer of Aging there's actually a DNA
clock that tells our bodies how old we
are we I could take your blood and read
it and I can tell you roughly when
you're going to die what what yeah we
can do that what are you looking for
we're looking for chemical groups that
get added and subtracted to our DNA the
long string in the cell you get chemical
modifications in predictable ways as you
get older starting from conception so
even in the womb even as a kid even as a
teenager you're aging based on this
clock that goes up linearly and where
you fit on that line is very accurate
that tells you your biological age but
how do you know when the person is going
to die is that just based on straight
lines is it Actuarial Table though the
human average human lifespan is 86 and
is that what you mean or is there could
you see something specific in my line
that would say
you're headed for 68 sorry uh no it's
not not specific but what it's based on
is machine learning based on thousands
of people's code of methylation on the
genome and comparing that to their
health and their date of death oh that's
so interesting so if you were to take my
blood right now what would you look for
exactly we would read the methylation
the camp these are chemicals hydrogen
and oxygen bound to the DNA chemically
physically bound
um and those accumulate as you get older
in very predictable ways in fact they're
so predictable that we can use the same
clock to measure the dog's age and a
human's age Whoa all based on
methylation right okay what causes
methylation well there are two classes
of enzymes the ones that add the methyl
chemicals and those that subtract it
okay how do I take a boatload of ones
that subtract it Ah that's what we're
working on now here's the key level two
aging reset which we can do by some of
the things that I'm doing in my life
yeah probably you are too those aren't
permanent changes you can't just do that
and expect that take take one treatment
and you go on living for another 10
years okay because level two isn't as
permanent it's somewhat permanent than
level one but level three is truly
permanent it you could reset yourself 10
years and then go back and then wait
another 10 years and potentially reset
the clock again if you know how to do
that and we're just starting to figure
out how to do that the secret to being
healthy is being happy the secret to
being healthy is being happy the more
stressed out you are the more you feel
like you're living out of alignment with
your goals and dreams the more you feel
like you're not making any kind of
progress in your business or your career
the more you feel like the work you do
doesn't matter and your relationships
don't matter that's going to lead you
down a path of anxiety depression
illness sickness disease suicide it's a
it's a really dangerous slippery slope
but the more you feel happy that today
matters that good things are going to
happen to you guess what they're more
likely to actually really happened
people ask me all the time Evan how are
you so positive all the time well I'm
not positive all the time I mean that's
an impossibly high standard but I try
not to be negative that much and when
negative things happen to me I try not
them I try not to let them ruin my
entire day let alone my entire week or
my entire month right people lost her
are shocked when they find out that I'm
41 years old they ask me how old am I am
41 born in 1980 like what how are you 41
you look a lot younger like well thank
you but I think a lot of it has to do
with happiness like when you love the
thing that you're actually doing when
you're excited when you have energy it
it exudes through you and has the impact
on other people as well I've been asked
on a bunch of Health shows what's your
number one secret for good health and
people expect to hear diet or exercise
or sleep I think the number one secret
for good health
is being happy
is loving the work that you're doing is
feeling like you're doing something
important and so maybe that's backed up
by the science by now but it feels
intuitively right to me and let me share
with you a couple ways how to do it okay
well that's great Evan be happy
well how do we actually do it so let me
share some things that have worked in my
life that I that hope can have an impact
on yours as well so number one is try to
run a no crisis life I know crisis
business and I know Christ is life one
of the things that I stressed out over a
lot when I first started my company was
always being at the beck and call of
other people I used to pride myself on
responding to emails really quickly I
used to use Outlook back in the day and
anytime an email came in there was a
little alert that came off alert new
email like oh and so I had to stop what
I was doing and then go respond to this
email
and that that cycle would reinforce
itself because anytime somebody then
responded they say wow you're so fast on
answering email
and that would make me want to answer it
even faster the next time what I ended
up finding out though was I kept
dealing with other people's emergencies
other people's requests for my time
other people's agenda for what they
wanted me to do and I dealt with all
those things and I never got the stuff I
wanted to do it never got done because I
kept being distracted to go answer these
emails or respond to that message
and so I had to make a conscious choice
to say I want to run a no crisis
business
and if a client needs me for something
that is urgent I don't want that kind of
client if we need to respond to customer
service which I believe is really
important I'm going to hire people to
help me do that but I I don't want to be
in the business where I have to be on
call
urgent responding to people because it
stresses me out and I don't want to be
in that business so how can you design a
no crisis business same thing for uh
your life you know for me
I love living in this condo a lot of the
stuff is taken care of you know we don't
have roof issues or having to mow the
lawn or things that break down and
having to call somebody and because the
air conditioner is broken or the toilet
doesn't work or oh I mean all the stuff
I built a 5 000 square foot custom home
and sold it to move into the condo
because it's it's a much lower crisis
life
and when you don't have a lot of crisis
in your life and in your business holy
cow you can be a lot happier and that
positivity allows you to be more
creative to be more productive to care
more about others to give more into
others when you're stressed out not only
is it bad for your health you're not
showing up for other people right you're
not being caring for other people you're
not thinking of other people you're not
investing into your customers or your or
your relationships or your team because
you're still too stressed out dealing
with your own issues but when you can
relieve some of those things it allows
you to pour into other people just a a
quick example from my life the past
three weeks have been actually pretty
stressful
um we have been looking at different
real estate options we have been looking
at different Financial options I'm I'm
diving deep into uh buy borrow die if
you look at that up as a financial
strategy I've been learning about crypto
I've been learning about nfts I've been
learning about infinite banking
pause
good afternoon this is your building
superintendent thank you for your
patience
all Elementary
both towers are fully operational enjoy
the rest of your name
so that's a great example right like
sure that's a minor Interruption to me
filming videos for you guys but a lot of
stuff is just taken care of so the past
two weeks have been have been
more stressful and have led to things
bleeding into my calendar I've let them
happen I didn't put enough guard rails
around my calendar think of blood into
my calendar and I'm doing things on days
that I normally aren't doing things and
it's led to me feeling more anxiety and
stress and so over the weekend this past
weekend I decided you know what I'm
doing things on the day that I said I
was going to do things on and that's it
and it means saying no to people and as
a result
uh I'm filming this on a Tuesday since
then it was Sunday it's like oh
life feels good again
life feels really good again why I'm so
happy again there's so much more energy
again
because I feel like I'm back in control
and so setting up a no crisis business
no crisis life
can free up just so much energy for you
and will make you a lot happier step
number two to make that happen is be in
control of your calendar
you have goals you have Ambitions of
what a dream life looks like for you
right perfect your actions need to map
to your ambitions so what's in your
calendar should reflect your goals you
say you want to be here you say you want
this kind of uh marriage this kind of
body this kind of business this kind of
financial success whatever your goals
are great until their habits until
you're doing the work nothing's gonna
happen you're never gonna achieve that
thing without it being a habit that
you're doing consistently so where are
your habits tracked in your calendar
show me your calendar and you'll be able
to see your outcomes
so you have to be protective over your
calendar and the stress that I had over
the past couple weeks was because I let
things run over my calendar too much and
I had to take back control when somebody
wanted to meet with me because I became
obsessed about something one of the
things I fight with as I get obsessed
over things and so I became obsessed
with under understanding nfts and
Discord and buy borrow die and all sorts
of these Concepts and so I want to meet
with somebody and I want to learn it and
so yes okay yeah I could squeeze that in
there or I could squeeze this in here
and then I wasn't getting the other
stuff done that I was supposed to do on
those days so let the stress
so same thing for you what are your
goals what do you want to accomplish you
have enough time when people say I don't
have enough time
audit your schedule
like if you were gonna sit next to you
and watch what you're doing all day is
every hour that you're spending really
productive is every hour you're spending
really intentional probably not right so
before you decide to do something like
give up on sleep people ask me how much
do you sleep I sleep as long as I need
to sleep I don't set an alarm in the
morning and I sleep as long as my body
tells me to sleep
yeah I think before worrying about
giving up sleep you don't have to only
sleep five hours a night you know I'll
sleep seven and a half to eight and a
half hours a night
right some some days more some days less
but that's my typical range that's what
my body needs depending on how busy a
day I had the night before
you worry about giving up an hour of
sleep audit how you're doing with the
time that you're awake you know if
you're gonna sleep eight hours perfect
you're awake for 16 hours or 16 of your
hours with intention with efficiency
with with Clarity of how you're going to
spend that time probably not right so
before you worry about now you're you're
not being productive or intentional with
your 16 hours what makes you think that
now you're going to be productive and
intentional with 20 hours
yeah and now you've slept four Less
hours
right so Focus instead on the hours that
you are awake and put in your calendar
your goals have to map to the actions
that you've got right you say you want
this show it to me in your calendar and
then put guard rails up around those
things it really really matters when you
can do that it takes a few hard no's
because people will want you to do
things and they'll want you to do things
on their timelines and that may mean you
have to say no you will have to say no
you'll have to say no to family you have
to say no customers you have to say no
to the team
but when you can set up the right time
to make things happen it makes things so
much happier and easier for everybody so
as an example I film my videos on a
Tuesday today's a Tuesday I don't know
when the video is going to be released
but I film it on a Tuesday so I can stay
in the zone of just creating all I have
to worry about today is making lots of
YouTube videos yesterday was Monday and
I'm I'm only focused on my team
and so my team knows that hey if they're
messaging me on a Tuesday it better be
urgent like it better be crazy urgent
and I run a no crisis business so it
better be something insane otherwise
don't message me on a Tuesday right
because it's going to interrupt my flow
it means I have to stop doing this video
to see what message you sent and so that
better be really really really really
important and that very rarely comes up
it's not that it's actually no crisis
we'll have something every now and then
that comes up
but they know that it it better be just
insanely important so it very rarely
happens
so I'm not there for my team on a
Tuesday right I'm not there for my team
on a filming day like this but I'm all
in on Mondays
I'm all in helping my team on Mondays
and so what I do is I ask them hey if
you need me within 24 hours email me
if you need me within a week then let's
discuss it on our Monday call we're
going to meet you on Monday let's
discuss it on Monday save up the things
that are important and save it for
Monday for our calling I will be there
not distracted not checking my phone not
thinking YouTube not thinking about
anything else except you on Monday and
what that does is allow you to really
over deliver on the thing that you're
doing as opposed to being scattered
bringing down all over the place
so Chunk in your time and then setting
up the guard rails around that so that
people don't step all over it is really
really important and when you can feel
like there's always a spot on your
calendar to get that thing done
it reduces stress dramatically
so if I'm worried about my YouTube
channel like oh my gosh you gotta make
videos when are we going to make videos
when you don't have it in your calendar
and when you don't feel like you have
enough time how much of your stress
comes from you feeling like you don't
have enough time to do something
right
raise your hand is that you right how
much of your stress comes from you
feeling like you do not have enough time
if you had a spot on your calendar where
you knew you would have the time to do
it it reduces a lot of the stress so for
me Tuesday is going to be YouTube day if
I get an idea for making videos if I'm
thinking about making content I know oh
I've got Tuesday to do it I'll send
myself an email
and on Tuesday I'll get to it
Wednesday is my project day so when I
have ideas for what I want to do in my
business to grow at other projects to
work on if I'm working on my funnels or
my landing page or my book or whatever
I'm working on I have a spot on my
calendar for it so I don't stress out I
was like I don't have enough time to do
things yes I do I've designed my life
around it I'm just gonna hit it on
Wednesday I'm not gonna allow
distractions to carry me off course
right it's being willing to let go of
the little balls to go for the big ones
you either you have to pick you're
either constantly taking these little
balls and getting these little wins
answering super promptly on email
responding everybody right away taking
out these little small bites all the
time
but then never having time to work on
the big project
or you chunk off time to work on your
big projects in life and your business
and that means some of these little
balls are going to drop and that's okay
and you can't judge yourself for losing
some of those because what you're going
to make here is Magic
okay Chunk in your time setting up the
rails becomes super important and the
last thing I say is you have to love the
actual process you want to be happy love
your work how much time do you spend
working a lot right especially if you're
not sharing you spend a lot of time
working love your work the number one
rule for Success from the people that I
profiled from entrepreneurs to athletes
to musicians like you love the actual
thing that you're doing where a lot of
entrepreneurs get caught up is you love
the end result
you love the impact that it can make you
love the idea of buying a house or or
riding a jet plane or whatever the
outcome
but you don't love the path to get there
and if you're just I'll do whatever it
takes you won't you won't do whatever it
takes to get to the outcome and you'll
be stressed out to the max along the way
so rather than doing that flip it to say
I need to love the work that I'm doing
and have it provide economic value to
other people so I can get paid to do it
that's a secret that the outcome was
fantastic it's great awesome hey I got a
million subscribers where's the thing I
got a million subscribers back there
great that's the outcome I love helping
like I love making these videos I love
feeling like this video will matter
means something
if you're only chasing the number you're
never going to get there and you're
going to hit your life in the process
good health I firmly believe comes down
to happiness yes diet exercise all of
that but if you are stressed out if you
hate your life if you despise who you're
hanging out with it's just really hard
to be healthy
where if you can now with intention
design a life
where happiness is a priority how many
times have you designed your calendar in
your life around you being happy what a
concept
that happened I guarantee you you're
going to be healthier you're going to
feel
like you're contributing a lot more
you're going to have a lot more energy
you're going to be a better person for
the people around you and you're going
to build a much better business in the
process as well
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome to learn
The Five Habits that will improve your
health check the video right there next
to me I think you'll love it continue to
believe and I'll see you there we know
it will allow us to live longer it will
give us more energy it will boost our
willpower they said the blueprints of
life you know all diseases are created
from genes